[Music]
[Applause]
the eyes of Texas were upon this team
tonight to see how they would respond in
the wake of the news about their
teammate Andruw Jones what a performance
in two overtimes 99-98 the Longhorns go
to two and two in the big 12 TCU
despite a great effort especially the
second half
defaults a one-in-three a weak point
the emotions the tears tears of joy here
tonight after the two overtime win let's
go to Alex coach this was no ordinary
game Andrew Jones in the hospital
fighting for his life what emotions are
going through your mind right now I've
been proud of our guys where they fought
and battled TCU's a really really good
team and obviously they meant a lot of
big plays I made it tough on us our guys
really wanted to win for Andrew he's the
one that's been on our minds in our
hearts and I'm really proud of the way
they thought I hope Drew's listen to
right now I hope you know if you love
him what message do you have for him if
he is listening or his family's watching
what message do you have for them well
I'm just proud of the way our getting
there in battle and Andrews the best
fighter on our team and you know he's
got a fight ahead of him but I know he's
really gonna fight and I guys really fed
off of his spirit tonight thanks Chuck
like thanks Alex great job tonight can't
say any more than that and that guy
right there as we said in the open
there's no better guy that I would want
to handle all those situations and he
handled it today
like a plus plus